tired I'm tired of my mind racing with
thoughts faster than a pen could ever
write it's adding me to life selling my
body with adrenaline to chase that one
goal I've always craved
in a world that never asked for a
egotistical behaviour that people will
never be able to work at the tune to
hold together to fix the real issue and
I trust but it's only messed up because
of our body mutilation are being pumped
with chemicals that they can't even
stand
castration without anesthetics being
kept in dark and natural spaces torn
away from their powers have simply
killed because there's no Jesus for them
and workers are treated just as badly
with the nails falling off through
infection and finding themselves a
massive massive amounts of debt that
keeping josephus and why to feed our
massive appetites which by the way it's
killing us energy I'm tired
why am I tired because everything I'm
choosing to do is hostile not only to
the world but to myself I'm living for
the fleeting moments and I've forgotten
what it's like without the high of being
acknowledged and praised by the other
mindless drones that we call a
civilization by the likes the favorites
the [ __ ] love heart sometimes we
doesn't just shut off our thoughts and
focus on something less serious because
no we can't save the world
single-handedly we can do our bit but at
the end of the day
once and if we're not enjoying it
what is the point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]